uh let's go next to
um where are we going to go
let's go to uh michael from florida
michael from florida you're on the air
hi david can you hear me yes i can
great thank you so much for having me
it's a real pleasure oh the pleasure's
all on this side of the microphone
well i wanted to call as a uh oh boy
roman catholic
yeah um you're cutting in and out
unfortunately
i'm sorry i'm trying to read something
at the same time so i was raised as a
christian since a kid
um and i just wanted to call in and
point out the fact
that there are many christians out there
who
do not buy into the trump cult
kool-aid right that's true
you know i spent a lot of time really
attacking the
just the blatant hypocrisy that exists
in the christian community
so while i would say you know i'm still
conservative on some
issues um
the the conservative christian movement
stopped being christian a long time ago
but by your definition of christianity
you're saying right right the moral
and theological way that they're
supposed to be
communicating their faith um sharing it
through
faith hope and love rather than forcing
the government
um to try to you know demand that
everybody be christian
but i think that um freedom of religion
means freedom for
christianity essentially right it's a uh
it's a christian supremacy in a sense
right i've even heard of a term called
christian dominionism right
they essentially argue that um the
founding fathers really were
intending the entire time for this to be
like a
not just a signing city on the hill but
a shining city on the hill for god you
know it's
right the whole point of um the united
states kind of existing is for
you know to kind of bring christianity
around the world et cetera et cetera
yeah i mean the the liberal christian
movement is a it's a it's
it's not a trivial movement and you know
it's important to remember also like
evangelical christians are far more
conservative
than catholic americans and there's
there's
um you know denominations that are far
more and less conservative as well
yeah the main thing i would point out is
like my stance on abortion
um now i do believe that it should be
avoided at all costs and that
it is fundamentally the destruction of
life now hold on
when you say at all costs if you were
about to give me a but when you if
you're
if it's at all costs there's really no
room for a but
is there no no that's i'm sorry that's
not what i mean
i'm saying we should form a society
where they aren't necessary
that's right and you know most people on
the left
would agree with you on that right the
christian thing to do would be to
support universal health care so that
mothers can see a doctor
you know good wages so that people can
just afford to keep a stable family
together you know those are the
christian things that you would be
supporting you have to
attack the socioeconomic roots of the
problem rather than just saying okay
we're going to make it illegal and
protected but what about access to
contraception because that's one of the
best ways to reduce demand for abortions
are you okay with contraception
see certain forms because um i think we
should get over the
the condom issue i kind of feel like um
a pregnancy prevented is better than a
pregnancy terminated
right um but at the same time a lot of
people point out well there's
um different forms of uh oral
contraception things like that
and some of them they they don't prevent
conception
so the conception is possible and it
releases
and destroys the uh the fertilize
yeah that's that's pretty scientifically
dubious i mean
you know when you're talking about
something that that science that is not
the prevailing view of science so i
think that that's maybe where the line
would be
where you would end up uh disagreeing
with with many on the left
um right because science draws the line
but that's not where a lot of christians
are going to draw the line right that's
exactly right
yep all right well good i appreciate
your insights thank you so much
all right there it is uh not all
christians are right-wing extremists and
that that is absolutely and completely
true